when you have a look at this function
that's being differentiated okay
remember that D on DX out the front it
means hey what's about to come next
I'd like you to differentiate this guy
okay what does this look like when you
see this function here right well this
is something multiplied by something
else right so I can use the product rule
on this so let's have a go I'm going to
and I encourage you actually do this
like get another color out and then
designate one of these to be you and the
other one to be V when it's a product it
doesn't really matter which ones which
because you could just switch them
around and it would still be the same
thing but we'll see this is a bit
different with the question rule so
here's the product rule I've got my U
and I've got my V now let's see if I can
use the product rule which is just and
if you want to write this for your first
line just to help you remember V U - + u
V - okay here we go that's the rule yeah
so I can um I can quote that I can use
it and it's sort of like using
Pythagoras theorem it's like oh this is
the rule which will always work with
these guys
same deal here now that I've got my you
and my V designated there I know my
product rule is going to use those in
this way vu - plus UV - let's begin from
the top
so what's V in this case 1 - X to the
power of 6 there it is done I don't have
to do anything it just write it down
okay the next thing along in the product
rule is you - let's have a look you -
over here yeah here's you so you - will
be 5 X so therefore good so there's the
first half now let's do the second half
what's you by itself great doesn't need
any change X to the 5 and then the last
piece V - let's have a look carefully
yeah very good your that minus sign
right right - 6m x 2.5 fantastic
so there we I've done all the
differentiation now and all that remains
is just the tidy this up algebraically
let's do it let's see here so one lot of
that I'll just write that down is 5x to
the fourth
now look at your index laws here I'm
gonna have minus five what x sub 5:10
very good so you got six of them here
four of them there X to the power of 10
and then lastly what happens to my plus
there becomes a minus y y yep that guy
there right so - and how many how many
terms are gonna get here six six what
yeah again 10 now it's interesting
because that means I can collect like
terms this 5x to the 4 just going to
hang out the front happy times okay now
by the way and I'm putting I use this
example deliberately when you have a
look at this solution it should make you
a little bit suspicious because if you
come back to this guy we can write it in
a different way to avoid using the
product rule have a think what could we
have done before we started
differentiating what could we have done
in the first line
before we turn to calculus just have a
look at this guy
we can yeah
so what are we done here all we've done
here is just expanded right like there's
nothing stopping you from working with
this guy before you even begin doing any
rules and differentiation and in fact
hopefully that confirms you oh yeah
5 X to the fourth that's not a
coincidence 11 X to the 10 that's also
not a coincidence
here's where it comes from okay yes it
is now this is really important right
often we will show you a technique with
something where you didn't need to use a
complicated technique so that you can
confirm for yourself all whichever way I
go I get the same answer later on like
with things like this there's not a
simple way to do it you've really got to
go for the most complicated way which is
what we're about to do right now let's
have a look
is this a thank you is this a product is
it a product it's a it's a question you
could write it as a product if you want
but it's already in a nice fold for a
question so I'm going to call this you
this is really important by the way the
top guy is you the bottom guy is V
unlike in the product rule where u and V
didn't matter U and V they do matter
here don't sit there you're gonna do
different things to these right so you
got to be very very careful with them
all right now that I know what's what
I'm going to write down the question
rule right here so then I got less in my
brain and I can just go through it one
step at a time
v u - what's on the top of you - u v -
all over V squared V squared okay all
right and just like before I'm now going
to go step by step just gonna take this
one a little bit at a time you know how
do you eat an elephant one bite at a
time what's V in this case yeah perfect
x squared plus one what's you -
here's you so you - will be negative -
and by the way hopefully you're noticing
my copious use of brackets right I don't
have to put brackets I could have just
said times negative two but there's so
many ways that this can go wrong I'm
going to keep those brackets there as
much as I can because it just makes it
clearer for me to deal with okay there's
V there's you - what's the next thing I
right - yeah it's it's a minor thing
negatives an adjective it describes
something like negative 2
whereas - is a verb it's like two things
that operate together but we get what
you meant what's you it's just it's just
the top doesn't need to be changed 5
minus 2x and then lastly V - 2 X isn't
it very good 2x down the bottom okay so
there's the numerator but we're not
quite done or / / what here's V here's
me and I'm just gonna square this whole
thing okay so it's V squared now some of
you might be thinking oh I know that's
gonna be X to the 4 plus 2x blah blah
but for reasons that will become a
little bit clearer later on there's no
actual reason there's very little
advantage to expanding this guy down the
bottom in fact well we we're actually at
this point having just written V squared
I don't need to use chain rule product
or questionable anymore the
differentiation is finished
it's done okay so I'm just gonna I'm
gonna leave that where it is but the
numerator is still a sort of garbled
mess and I know there's going to be some
collective like terms that I can do so
I'm going to just pause for a minute and
let you guys expand this on your own
simplify those terms together I'll give
it a head start and then we'll see what
you get
practice practice you mean this one here
you mean like when I'm choosing which
ones which
yes and the reason why you can know that
is come back to how he proved it I sent
you to be the top I set V to be the
bottom if I interchange them this would
not be the V down the bottom winner
it'll be u squared not V squared but
because of how we set it up and this is
out what